merci d'être avec nous notre gâteau vous
êtes sénateurs
RDPI c'est le groupe qui rassemble les
sénateurs de la majorité présidentielle
vous êtes vice-président de la
commission des affaires européennes et
de celle des Affaires étrangères
également on va évidemment parler de
votre audition hier de Laurence Boone et
des questions qui concernent l'Union
européenne mais d'abord vous l'avez
entendu dans le journal Elisabeth Bourne
a donc annoncé hier trois nouveaux
dispositifs pour aider les entreprises
et les collectivités à faire face à la
hausse des prix de l'énergie 12
milliards est-ce que vous admettez que
il y avait des trous dans la raquette
oui il y avait des trous dans la
raquette et c'est des choses que des
nous-mêmes en tant que sénateur on a
fait remonter auprès du gouvernement la
multiplication de mesures sectorielles
si elles permettent de faire je dirais
des mesures chirurgicales éviter les
effets de Ben elle a un problème de
lisibilité et donc à chaque fois on
découvre dès qu'on annonce une mesure
qu'il y a des populations des groupes
des secteurs qui sont pas concernés donc
c'est une bonne nouvelle parce que ça
complète un dispositif moi entendu le
vice-président Monsieur Philippe Laurent
de l'AMF d'ailleurs sont réjouir et
c'est une bonne chose parce que on parle
des collectivités locales mais il y a
les petites entreprises et il y a aussi
les grands établissements publics je
pense aux universités et comme il
m'arrive d'enseigner parfois en hiver je
peux vous dire déjà pour capter
l'abstention aujourd'hui c'est pas très
facile mais quand il fait froid et c'est
très compliqué de faire des
enseignements donc c'est important mais
ça concerne l'électricité la question du
gaz reste entière et c'est une autre
charge extrêmement élevée pour les
entreprises pour les particuliers mais
aussi pour les collectivités locales
notamment sur succès on va en parler
puisque vous en avez évidemment parlé à
Laurence Bonnières juste pour les
collectivités il y a ce cet amortisseur
c'est comme ça que ça s'appelle
maintenant qui est mise en place est-ce
qu'il faut en faire plus les
collectivités elle demande d'une
indexation de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement sur l'inflation une fois
aller jusque là pour vous moi je pense
que c'est totalement impossible parce
que si on index tout
enfin on connaît pas l'évolution de
l'inflation la France c'est le pays qui
résiste le mieux en matière d'inflation
dans la zone euro c'est une bonne chose
mais on peut pas faire de budget si
systématiquement on considère qu'il y a
du rattrapage partout la fonction
publique a eu une hausse de 3,5 %, c'est
que l'inflation est plus de 5 % alors
quand j'entends des gens qui travaillent
dans des grandes sociétés de l'énergie
qui demande si cette 10%, je suis
d'accord mais il y a peut-être un
problème
on va parler justement les deux ces
questions de l'énergie mais au niveau
européen cette fois puisque le
gouvernement ce qu'il cherche avant tout
c'est obtenir une baisse des prix de
l'énergie à l'échelle européenne et vous
avez auditionné justement hier Laurent
Voulzy à ce sujet c'est la secrétaire
d'État chargée de l'Europe content
calmer va venir nous parler de cette
audition
[Musique]
Jean Quentin bonjour Ariane bonjour En
Agathe
hier lors de cette audition le bilan du
dernier Conseil européen un maigre bilan
qui inquiète sur l'état de l'Union
européenne oui le Conseil européen qui
se tenait jeudi vendredi dernier il a
accouché d'une souris on peut le dire
alors que les attentes des Européens
sont grandes face à la crise de
l'énergie rencontre notre continent
notre continent dans son communiqué
final on lit simplement que le Conseil
européen demande à la Commission de leur
remettre de façon urgente je cite des
décisions concrètes sur l'ensemble des
mesures dont les interventions pour
dompter la volatilité des cours du gaz
alors hier face à la ministre des
affaires européennes de nombreuses
sénateurs se sont inquiétés de voir ces
négociations à 27 patinées on a entendu
par exemple André Richard apparentait à
l'air qui a relevé que la ministre elle
répétait souvent l'expression ça va
prendre un certain temps ça va prendre
un certain temps il a dit mais c'est
propositions elle devrait déjà être là
cela n'a pas l'air d'aller dans le bon
sens rapidement écoutez la réponse de la
ministre face à ces inquiétudes des
sénateurs
la raison pour laquelle ça prend du
temps au niveau européen c'est qu'il n'y
a pas un pays qui a un mix énergétique
qui ressemble à l'autre nous dépendons
très peu du gaz l'Allemagne et l'Italie
comme vous savez dépend beaucoup du gaz
et donc il faut arriver à 27 à se mettre
d'accord sur des mesures qui permettent
de
satisfaire les contraintes et de
répondre aux inquiétudes des uns et des
autres et qu'on pense qu'un quête
également les sénateurs c'est que le
moteur franco-allemand on a l'impression
qu'il est clairement en panne dans la
résolution de cette crise oui c'est vrai
et puis Emmanuel Macron est chancelier
la Scholl si le déjeuner ensemble
d'ailleurs avant-hier à l'Elysée trois
heures de rencontre pour unifier les
positions des deux pays il faut dire que
plusieurs dossiers entravent la bonne
entente franco-allemande on parle
notamment du projet du bouclier
antimicile sans la France que veut
l'Allemagne la viande combat européen
qui est à l'arrêt le plan de relance de
200 milliards lancé en solo par
l'Allemagne l'élargissement de lieu à
l'est du continent voulu par le
chancelier qu'elle la France n'est pas
favorable c'est quand même des sujets
majeurs il y a désormais de nombreux
points de friction écoutez l'analyse de
Laurence Boon à nouveau
et parfois un irritant pour d'autres
pays d'Union Européenne parce que ce
moteur qui s'impose mais à l'inverse il
y a de l'inquiétude un parmi nos amis
européens quand il y a ce sentiment que
le moteur franco-allemande n'avance pas
assez vite parce qu'il permet
effectivement de réconcilier des
positions qui sont différentes donc il
est là il est plus compliqué parce que
la situation énergétique est compliquée
mais justement l'idée avec le déjeuner
entre le président et le chancelier hier
était de faire un état des lieux de ce
sur quoi on pouvait avancer et accélérer
en commun
d'ici l'anniversaire du traité de
l'Elysée qui aura lieu le 22 janvier
2023 le traité de l'Élysée qui avait
scellé la réconciliation entre la France
et l'Allemagne après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale est lancé la corrélation entre
les deux puissances européennes un
dernier mot pour mentionner que Laurence
Boon a évoqué la crise que traverse
l'Allemagne et qui pourrait expliquer la
nervosité sur la scène européenne de
notre allié les également sont au milieu
d'une remise en cause de leur modèle
économique et social écoutez à nouveau
la ministre c'est un changement de
paradigme colossal pour pour l'Allemagne
il faut il faut s'en rendre compte c'est
l'ombrelle
militaires américaines qui avaient été
secoué par par le président Trump la
deuxième chose c'est la compétitivité
repose en largement sur une énergie pas
chère fournie par la Russie c'est
terminé et les exportations vers la
Chine et effectivement comme on est en
train de changer le poids relatif des
trois éléments de la stratégie envers la
Chine c'est presque une question
existentielle qui se posait ce modèle
alors on va revenir sur l'Allemagne dans
un deuxième temps si vous le voulez bien
mais déjà sur le Conseil européen le
fait que ça ne bouge rien concrètement
la semaine dernière ça vous inquiète sur
l'état de l'Union non on a l'habitude
c'est à dire que des négociations à 27
c'est compliqué et quand le sujet est
compliqué vous avez 27 pays qui a son
propre mix énergétique un mix
énergétique c'est pas simplement la part
de du gaz du pétrole de l'énergie
nucléaire on fait aussi de l'électricité
avec du gaz ou avec du charbon dans
certains pays c'est évident que c'est
compliqué ce que je regrette c'est que
quand il était décidé de lancer une
Union européenne de l'énergie il y a
maintenant presque 10 ans tous les pays
y compris le note à traîner des pieds et
maintenant on parle de remettre à plat
tout le marché de l'énergie et ce sera
un des projets lancé en 2023 et la
réponse de la ministre elle vous a
convaincu il faut que ça avance on a
demandé la Commission des nouvelles
mesures le 24 novembre c'est la
prochaine échéance on peut attendre une
telle échéance en tous les cas c'est
l'échéance institutionnelle c'est à dire
ce qui a été discuté là lors de ce
conseil c'était les propositions de la
Commission du 18 octobre dernier là il
est demandé à la Commission de revoir sa
copie pas seulement d'étudier le statut
un peu particulier
ibérique c'est-à-dire de l'Espagne et du
Portugal sur le plafonnement du prix du
15 mais de voir son application concrète
ça veut dire que si on fait se
découplage entre gaz électricité
certains gagneront comme la France et
d'autres y perdront comme l'Allemagne
donc ce qu'il faut c'est que les gains
et les pertes soient équilibrées une
chose je peux vous dire c'est pas un
chef d'État ou un ministre qui est
capable de régler ça c'est quelque chose
au sens où il faut trouver des c'est pas
un grand principe général c'est trouver
un système
non ce que je dis c'est que il faut du
temps d'échanges techniques un président
va pas passer 20 heures de réunion pour
peu qu'il ait la compétence
ultra technique pour le faire avec ses
26 autres partenaires que dire de la
relation franco-allemande on disait un
moteur habituellement on a vu qu'il a
fallu même organiser un déjeuner à
l'Elysée pour essayer de montrer que
tout n'était pas tout n'était pas cassé
entre la France et l'Allemagne on est au
point mort en ce moment et que la
Scholtz ça distingue déjà depuis
plusieurs années on note ça a été une
bataille pour le plan de relance la
contrepartie Madame Merkel a voulu finir
en beauté en faisant signer à l'arracher
un traité
de
je dirais d'investissement Union
européenne Chine que personne ne voulait
apparaît même parce que satisfaisait sa
méthode stand son industrie personnelle
on a eu le problème du spatial dont on
parle pas mais où les Allemands tentent
de plus en plus à faire qu'avec des sols
en voulant lancer leur propre base de
lancement offshore contre tous les
autres pays européens je dis tous y
compris la Suède et la et la Norvège qui
est associée à nous donc l'Allemagne
joue son intérêt particulier et son
intérêt économique
une sorte d'affrontement ça marquait
quelque chose la France je vous le dis
n'est pas isolée de temps en temps c'est
à ces années de monter au créneau
l'Italie l'Espagne la Pologne n'est pas
d'accord c'est peut-être à eux aussi
d'aller voir de temps en temps monsieur
schollz en disant on n'existe parce que
si on croit que ces deux représentants
vont tout régler à eux tout seul contenu
notamment sur l'énergie ou les
divergences sont très profondes parce
que les Allemands nous reprochent l'ont
engagement nucléaire et nous reproche
tout un tas de choses on s'en sortira
pas on restera sur du binational ou du
bilatéral et c'est pas satisfaisant et
oui une dernière question sur
l'Allemagne on entendait la ministre
dire qu'ils sont milieu d'un voilà d'un
tournant économique et social de leur
modèle vous vous êtes d'accord avec
cette analyse c'est voilà c'est un
renversement de situation pour eux à ce
qui se passe à l'échelle internationale
c'est totalement vrai c'est en plus on a
une coalition qui a des points de vue
très différents vous avez
des P les lib qui sont de plus en plus
critiques et qui sont très critiques et
même moteur sur les liens historiques
l'Allemagne a nourri économiquement avec
la Russie mais aussi avec la Chine et
puis on a le SPD dont une grande partie
de son financement comme les chrétiens
viennent de l'industrie allemande qui
elle fait ses bénéfices d'un côté une
énergie pas cher et dans notre côté une
chambre
la coalition est irraillée c'est le
problème de Monsieur chasse et on parle
souvent d'arrogance on dit que le
Président de la République français est
à Rogue en mais je pense que la position
de Monsieur Scholl c'est aujourd'hui est
assez arrogante la prédominance qu'il a
dans le moteur la dimension économique
de l'Union un moment où on passe à une
Europe qui est géopolitique et jouer
stratégique mais il faudrait qu'il
s'interroge un peu sur leur
responsabilité en tant que nation depuis
20 ans
[Musique]
a dit que le monde entrer dans sa
décennie la plus dangereuse depuis la
Seconde Guerre mondiale vous êtes
d'accord avec ça il y a contribué
évidemment évidemment d'autant que
aujourd'hui on se focalise beaucoup sur
ce conflit et c'est important il y a les
tensions grandissantes avec la Chine bon
je note qu'on en parle pas mais c'est un
des gros objets du conseil dans la
partie très civiline relation
internationale alors je regardais les
conclusions officielles du conseil il y
a pas un mot sur la Chine alors qu'ils
ont beaucoup parlé de l'aggravation de
l'agressivité croissante de la Chine et
puis il y a la question iranienne donc
on voit on est quand même dans un monde
qui peut exploser toutes parts et le
risque c'est pas simplement d'avoir un
conflit ouvert comme on en a aujourd'hui
en Ukraine c'est d'en avoir plusieurs à
la fois la Russie qui utilise la force
on peut en Ukraine mais aussi une forme
de soft power pouvoir un peu plus
sous-jacent plus discret grâce à des
organes d'influence notamment comme
comme les médias est-ce qu'on en fait
assez pour contrer ce soft power
notamment en Afrique alors une prise de
conscience j'étais à Rome il y a deux
semaines un des objets de la Réunion
qu'on avait avec d'ailleurs des
responsables américains africains
moyen-orientaux et italiens dont des
gens qui se retrouvent aujourd'hui
ministre du gouvernement de Georges et
donc
on a évoqué cette question et moi je
suis intervenu justement sur c'est plus
du sapin alors là c'est ce qu'on dit du
chapeau c'est du c'est de l'influence
tranchante de la Russie et nous savons
très mal faire nous avons un audiovisuel
extérieur qui nous raconte des belles
histoires qui diffusant FM qui n'est pas
écouté alors que les Russes et notamment
gueny à prigonzine qui est le patron de
Wagner développe des films très
populaires d'action où on met en scène
la Russian Gladys et pas assez ce qu'on
appelle le narratif c'est-à-dire que la
Russie elle fait pas simplement de la
désinformation elle fait aussi une
construction d'univers elle fond d'une
grande partie de son discours en Afrique
sur le statut de la France
commençantienne puissance coloniale donc
on l'a vu au Burkina Faso et je peux
vous annoncer d'ores et déjà que la
prochaine étape ça sera
vraisemblablement la Guinée ou
d'ailleurs RT news qui n'a plus le droit
d'émettre sur le territoire de l'Union
européenne à l'intention d'installer son
gérer son navire amiral pour sa
diffusion en français ils sont en
Afrique du Sud pour la diffusion en
anglais les moyens qui sont mis alors le
ministre des Armées et la ministre des
Affaires étrangères nous a dit que il y
allait y avoir un canal une chaîne qui
allait destinée aux jeunes africains
c'est important mais il faut savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on tient comme contre
discours comment on contre-argumente on
va parler de l'Ukraine et de la question
de l'armement pour ça on va aller à
Roanne où on retrouve Pierre Olivier
Véro bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous rédacteurs en chef de
l'hebdomadaire le pays et à Roanne
Pierre Olivier on fabrique des canons
César
à côté oui plus exactement les on les
intègre sur sur les camions au sein d'un
site qui a énormément recruté déjà c'est
ces dernières années qui atteint 1400
salariés et où effectivement la
production du César est effectuée
et vous avez une question justement
là-dessus au sénateur
oui monsieur gatelin bonjour Hier
Emmanuel Macron était à Bourges
justement dans un autre site Nexter où
sont également fabriqué les canaux César
il a parlé d'économie de guerre il des
solutions sont recherchées avec les
industriels pour pour augmenter le
rythme de production est-ce que
effectivement selon vous c'est une
priorité de parvenir à augmenter ses
cadences dans le contexte que nous
connaissons oui c'est évidemment une
priorité parce que le fait qu'on donne
18 canons César sur les 74 ou 78 qu'on
possédait qu'on en promet 12 autres
qu'on a des commandes qu'on doit honorer
à d'autres pays il faut augmenter la
cadence et le problème c'est quand on
parle d'économie de guerre attention on
n'est pas en 14-18 mais il faut
augmenter nos capacités de production et
c'est un vrai problème de nos
industriels français de l'armement ils
ont vécu une période de paix où en gros
avec une assez bonne rentabilité malgré
tout parce que ils vivent sur la
commande publique nationale et le fait
aussi que nos ministères aide beaucoup à
l'exportation quand il s'agit d'investir
et quand on a demandé une deuxième
chaîne de production à Dexter on dit ah
mais c'est compliqué est-ce que vous
nous garantissez 10 ans de commande il y
a un moment il faut prendre des risques
j'étais au dernier salon de
eurosatori j'ai rencontré le ministre de
la Défense
Ukrain qui était venu là et il me dit il
y a 72 exposants ici 72 industriels je
suis tous allé les voir je dois demander
de nous aider il y en a un seul qui a
offert du petit matériel alors nous nos
états ce sacrifie donne mais les
industriels de l'armement se vivent
assez peinards et par ailleurs on a un
problème de production c'est que on fait
des bijoux on est un peu trop influencé
dans l'armement français par gérer la
haute couture ou l'industrie du luxe
donc on produit les armements
extrêmement sophistiqués extrêmement
coûteux extrêmement long conduire et il
faudrait avoir des gammes intermédiaires
les Américains sont battent beaucoup
moins il y a pas besoin que ça brille
comme une voiture chromée
et si vous industriels aujourd'hui de
prendre leur part de responsabilité une
autre prennent pas de risque et une
industrie pratiquement sans risque je le
dis malheureusement ils prennent des
risques en rechercher développement en
termes de production il reste passif à
un moment où on a besoin qu'il s'engage
davantage le 9 novembre prochain à
Toulon Emmanuel Macron va fixer le cap
de la prochaine loi d'orientation
militaire qu'est-ce qu'il faut pour vous
plus de moyens ou un cap différent il
faut déjà il faut repenser l'ensemble
des besoins de la stratégie ça c'est une
chose on en a parlé avec on a une
réunion en off avec le ministre des
Armées cette semaine donc nous avions un
certain nombre de choses que je peux pas
dévoiler évidemment puisque quand même
la primeur du président puis tout n'a
pas été arbitré mais il faut que on
fasse à la fois cette sens de la revue
nationale stratégique nos besoins on
aura un cadre plus réannuel donc une
nouvelle LPM mais il faut d'abord voir
les perspectives et les besoins ses
besoins on l'a vu grâce à ce conflit ont
évolué il y a bien sûr cette idée d'une
économie de guerre entre guillemets
c'était une capacité de production en
veillant que ça ne tue pas l'économie
civile non plus parce que on n'est pas
non plus en conflit total c'est quelque
chose d'absolument
indispensable
notre commission tous les cas le bureau
de la commission des affaires étrangères
et de la défense du Sénat devrait
recevoir un petit peu des documents pour
que nous alimentions ça c'est aussi la
volonté du ministre et du Président
c'est d'associer pleinement les
parlementaires spécialisés sur cette
question et je crois que c'est vraiment
nécessaire parce que moi je suis allé en
adopacifique récemment Nouvelle
Calédonie on en parlait il y a une
situation globale qui pose question qui
nécessite d'avoir une AR différents sans
doute une mobilisation plus importante
de la population donc on parle d'un
service civique
renouvelée il va falloir aujourd'hui
aussi parce qu'une armée s'habille pas
hors sol c'est pas quelque chose qui va
négocier ses contrats ou ses besoins
elle doit aussi être présente auprès de
la population pour faire valoir je
dirais sa réalité et sa capacité
Pierre-Olivier Véro à Roanne et
évidemment Roanne marqué par ce père de
famille qui a violemment molesté
l'agresseur présumé de sa fille
oui une information qui est sortie
localement ce week-end qui qui a
largement débordé dans l'actualité
nationale
engendrant des débats de société et
peut-être symptomatique monsieur
sénateur qui en pensez vous d'une
population qui aurait moins confiance en
la justice en l'autorité
il y a beaucoup de marques de soutien à
ce père de famille donc il s'est fait
justice lui-même
à l'encontre de l'agresseur on va dire
présumé même si tu es présumé innocents
bien sûr tant qu'il n'est pas jugé de sa
fillette voilà est-ce que est-ce que ce
fait divers est révélateur de d'une
certaine perte de confiance et si oui
que faudra-t-il que faudra-t-il
actionner pour pour rétablir ce lien de
confiance et alors moi j'ai trois points
de vue celui de l'ancien homme de presse
puisque j'ai été directeur au journal
Libération et c'est un journal qui dans
les années 70 a commencé
c'est que des exemples étaient
révélateurs de problématiques plus
larges on en a abusé je le dis
clairement ça conduit
Marguerite Duras ça a condamné dans la
presse la maman du petit Grégory donc je
crois qu'il faut être quand même très
prudent avec ce que Michel Foucault
appelait l'exempleification c'était à
partir d'un fait
essayer de donner une démonstration plus
générale donc je pense que les
politiques notamment la presse en parle
on en parle beaucoup plus parce qu'il y
a des réseaux sociaux les années 70 ce
genre de situation horrible était
monnaie courante ils avaient peut-être
moins de raisonnement alors je comprends
vous vos yeux journal s'y intéresse
parce que c'est une question de
proximité mais la prestationale va
peut-être un petit peu trop loin
là-dessus après moi je comprends le père
je ne le je ne je dirais je ne dresse
pas mais
quand on sait les procédures la longueur
des procédures les preuves qu'il faut
apporter la capacité de la justice
qu'est-ce qui va se passer ce jeune
homme et c'est en tant que parlementaire
il est la famille ou les proches on
passe faire justice semaine bon il y a
été roué de coup il y a eu 10 jours
d'arrêt temporaire de travail
ça va peut-être le marquer cette fête
taper dessus peut-être qu'il aura un
traumatisme mais la petite fille de 6
ans elle va le traîner combien de temps
c'est à dire qu'il y a un moment moi je
veux bien entendre et d'ailleurs le juge
en charge l'affaire ou les deux dossiers
sont attachés a dit la question
principale c'est quand même le dossier
de l'agression contre la petite fille
donc c'est toujours dangereux de se
faire justice soi-même parce qu'on peut
se tromper là quand même il y a eu une
vérifications non c'est pas un laxisme
c'est une société qui devient dingue
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui
il y a une délinquance sexuelle qui qui
est nourri qui est très difficile à
construire c'est un problème d'éducation
quand on parle de cela dans les écoles
il y a une partie des qui veulent pas
qu'on en parle il y a pas que les écoles
c'est compliqué en famille c'est
compliqué parce que parfois il y a des
problèmes intra-familleaux et donc c'est
des sujets difficiles mais je crois que
d'abord il faut se dire que la justice
est là elle doit évidemment juger mais
elle doit comprendre aussi que ces
procédures sa lenteur la torture
confesse subir quand vous voyez c'est
différent mais les les
procès qui est actuellement sur le
terrorisme moi j'ai quelques amis qui
sont dans les familles de victimes
c'est terrible de devoir ressasser tout
ça revenir alors à la fois ça aide un
peu au deuil mais le processus
judiciaire son exposition médiatique qui
provoque moi j'aimerais pas être le papa
ou la maman de la petite fille
aujourd'hui comment ils vivent ils
vivent reclus j'ai vu que le père
d'ailleurs regrette mais c'est terrible
de lui imposer à lui en plus cette mé et
puis ce jeu de politique qui récupère
l'affaire merci André gatelin on
remercie Pierre Olivier Giraud également
et
regarde vous le paierez Juan
sur l'agression l'agression d'une
fillette mais la société en est moins et
puis la une du pays d'entre loin tout
autre sujet il cherche un lieu de
tournage à Tarare merci beaucoup ciao
Olivier Véro d'avoir été avec nous merci
André gatelin d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi-heure dans
20 minutes dans le cas des territoires
on vous emmène à Nîmes découvrir la
Maison Carrée je ne sais pas si je
connaissais
Andrés de la ville pour sa candidature
au patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO on ira
la découvrir et d'abord on a quand même
notre prochaine invité c'est
[Musique]